that day when the bus driver asked me to
get up
i had this feeling come over me and felt
like
harry your tummy was holding me down
hands were holding me down on one
shoulder
and so john of truth hands were holding
me down on another show
and i was glued to the seat and i could
hear
the white passioners
saying she gotta move she got a room
that's the laws you gotta move and i
felt like this is my time to take a
stand for justice
my name is claudette colvin and in 1955
i refused to give up my seat to a white
passenger on the bus in montgomery
alabama
nine months before rosa parks i was 15
years old
and the rule and the segregation that a
white person had to sit in front of you
and you sit behind them and so the bus
driver
asked me to get up i was shouting it's
not constitutional rights i'm not going
to move and that's when the bus the
policeman dragged me off the bus
most people ask me
when you're afraid
when i was a teenager i was afraid but i
was more angry at these white passioners
and then they took me and booked me
i still vividly can hear that the sound
of the key go
and
i was terrified and i started reciting
the lord's prayer i will be there on in
earth as it is in heaven and i was just
praying for help you know praying that
they would go and let my parents know
that i was in jail
my mama said yeah claudette i think he
was anointed by god to do this i said i
don't think so much i just had i just
felt
that this was not right
i just wanted people to come together
and unify
and fight the segregation
you